so so I never seen you before but you  know why the girls my leg  something like that down at one point I  wanted to be a DJ should be Jenny hey  got a DJ there listen ladies tonight we  gonna have a good time we gonna turn all  the way up  you fought for me the first day we met  what do you really want now Cass that is  you bro when the feats are supposed to  drop man we are waiting you came out  here to do something now you're just  giving up  give me a break I'll fight every day  that's my occupation I'll fight every  day not even trying to follow you so now  you know my life yeah do you do you know  me yeah cuz I live here  the city of dreams right  [Music]  do you understand how important this is  and how important part is since  everything this is our voice this will  be this is all we have left  [Music]  a great time a lot of fun at night safe  to say I'm starting remember why I moved  out here nice to meet you  [Music]  you